well let's talk about a little
digression cuz it's not all about the
work you know on the set with the ladies
good hands there Melissa I want to talk
a little bit about how you guys interact
with fans how how social media plays a
part in what you do and what's pretty
cool is that Jackie and I are sitting
here because I was harassing you on
Twitter enough for you to follow me and
now we're tweeting once or twice a week
and obviously well can we tell you yeah
it is responsible for me being on
Twitter for years he kept on saying you
need to get on the Twitter and what did
you say I was no no I'm so scared of it
no and we kind of made a deal that I
would get on Twitter and you would move
to LA that was pretty much like the same
yeah it was in that conversation I think
that we both had made that decision I
really didn't want anything you didn't
know cuz everybody knows where you are
your business but my girlfriend Eva even
myself she told me I said why do you
know she said because it keeps you
current and relevant I was like well
that man and she's right we wouldn't be
sitting here now but it keeps you right
in the now of the moment yeah and you
have to be a curious person to be on
Twitter
you can't just be on there just to get
fans yeah it really doesn't work that
way or to get fans to watch your stuff
you really have to know what you're
talking about yeah otherwise people know
that you're not that bright or you're
just a liar and you can't be a liar
which I have just found out when you lie
and really does catch up with you you
know what I mean on Twitter and in real
life yes you can't keep it together you
know what I mean and your work suffers
when you need you're just covering up
all the time it really is just a mess
yeah most what's your like social media
policy in terms of like how much you can
give of yourself and you know share
everything with the fans and that all
day I really I pretty much just like if
I think of a joke I'll tweeted or if I
you know if I want to talk about the
show that night I'll tell everyone to
tune in um but I don't like talk about
like I did this today with this person
at this time at this place and this is
my blood type and my social security
number I'm very I'm kind of very like
alright this I'm gonna tweet this now
cuz I had this idea yeah but I'm not on
it a lot now jack hey you give a lot of
very personal sort of heartwarming
advice where did that come from from me
wanting to be a mentor to young ladies
specifically from age 16 to 54 and I say
that specifically because sometimes you
look across the table and you're the
only woman like that book lean in by
Sheryl Sandberg you you you're not the
only person out there you can look
across the table and see like the Yahoo
woman I met her I was gagging cuz you
don't have anybody Hillary Clinton and
she looks across the room there's nobody
there but there are they're out there so
put it out there so people can know
you're not alone you know what I mean so
I don't feel like oh and you come in
your room and I know you close your door
you go cuz it'll beat you down cuz the
husband the children and women feel
guilt and I'm telling feel guilt less
yeah it's harder but you know you know
if you're successful you're gonna be
alone even if you're married because
you're gonna be in that hotel room or a
gig at some point by yourself having to
deal with something dreadfully lonely
which is where's my check and um you
know I write that now you have Twitter
to keep you connected you connected so
you don't go into some pit of of
self-pity sometimes yeah do you ever
feel like that the fans demand like they
want the sort of insider who is melissa
rauch kind of thing um I don't know what
do you think I should do more of an
insider thing I think you're doing it
you're doing it right I will do whatever
you tell me to do on Twitter de Bourbon
really you're responsible for getting me
on Twitter
yeah so you tell me what I need to do
look you're doing it okay thank you okay
so okay so you guys are getting a little
bit of your voices out but I want to
talk about your voices voices cuz both
of you another thing you guys have in
common is so much of what you do is
based on your characters voices that are
kind of like your real voices but not
quite so unless I'll start with you
because Bernadette I know where
Bernadette comes from but can you give
the people where does the boys come from
Bernadette's voice is very similar to my
mother's um
except without the Jersey accent say but
um yeah it's uh it's my mother it's not
quite quite that high but it's
it's in that in that tone that rain and
the people think that's what you're
supposed to sound like at all time when
people say hi to you and then you don't
sound like that do they yeah yeah yeah I
think like sometimes I'll get
recognizing and they'll hear my voice
and be like oh that that's not you like
yeah that's right yeah like you're
putting on a fake voice for them in real
exactly exactly what about you Jackie
where did where did Sandra's voice that
real high pitch where did that come from
the first time uh I had a girlfriend in
school her name was Val Jean Dean and
she had asthma and we were out one day
and this is one gave me my first joint
yeah and and and wine anyway Boone's
Farm no no no no anyway cheap wine and
we were out and it was Christmas and it
was cold and we were outside smoking my
arm so coach she's like just nuts well
sin or to open fire yeah Frost nipping
at your ass and I never forgot that
Lucille Ball and Mae West so it's the
combination all jewelry yeah and the
walk just came from I don't know one day
my skirt was so tight it was every day
and I just you know and they laughed and
I said just do some more in the late
great Brandon Tartikoff
with my Angels I took to you earlier
about angels yeah he uh gave me the job
cuz I was not gonna get the job and he
said no she's got the job you know and
he said no just do more of that and you
know you kind of go in there too much
know you know and Barnes like that now
do that do that you know cuz people
won't tell you to do that cuz I can tell
you from your character the first time
you've definitely evolved I can see this
cuz they want you to do more and they've
written it for you you know and I mean
otherwise you might hell back you think
you know what I mean you might have been
okay she alright you know what I mean
they always want more out of Bernadette
do they always want more character and
more everything cuz I see what you're
saying with with Sandra certainly um
they don't specifically say it no um I
think you know the great thing about our
writers is that it's very much like in
this correctly you know they're that's
more you they're fantastic it's it's all
it's all there we get these little
presence of these he's fantastic cousins
well held it's the script promo I'm Jim
read your jokes look at this
no I'm just kidding all right so the
last thing about the public the public
personal life do you ever miss the
anonymity like it's all great it seems
all great on the outside but you ever
miss any any of the the freedom to just
be able to go do your thing and not have
anyone point at you or any of that stuff
um I definitely I mean I feel like I'm
doing what I've always loved to do so I
can't complain about that there's you
know some weird things like just I I
really like to go to like the grocery
store of my sweats and I'm realizing
recently that I'm horrifying people with
my minor makeup and my I often dress
like a fourteen-year-old prepubescent
boy in my time off like that is my I go
to look which is what exactly it's like
a baseball huh actually when I lived in
New York I was walking to do a show one
night and it was like I was walking I
think from like it was my apartment on
the Upper East Side to one of the clubs
and I was in a baseball hat in a jean
jacket and I had a book bag on which is
like basically how I would like to dress
all the time and I was passing by a
school that was getting out and I got
felt a hand on my backpack that pulled
me back and it was the principal and I
turned around he was like oh my god I'm
so sorry I thought you were one of the
kids who is getting at her like that so
basically that's mmm um that's how I
dress yeah like a schoolboy
on the Upper East Side of New York yeah
Jack hey do you do you miss it at all
just a little bit of the anonymity and I
miss the fact that I can't go on a date
with a guy and and then we go up for a
couple of dates and then they I realize
they're only going out with me because
I'm Jackee that I hate yeah yeah and I
don't mind it but it's like and I didn't
think it was me but it's like man like
you know they're cool they're cool
they're cool then you take him to a big
a-list party and they lose their mind
you realize it really is that's what I
miss I miss this how do you meet a guy
that how would you meet again well I'm
on the corner of handing out flies
bonobos calm the official outfitter of
the Reuben report enter code TRR to zero
for twenty percent off your first
purchase